- It's my pleasure to
introduce Dr. Meghan Miller
who is an assistant
professor in the department
of psychiatry and behavioral sciences
in the the MIND Institute at UC Davis.
I'm not going to read
all your stuff Meghan,
I'm sorry but that's the end of the day.
And Meghan's going to talk to
us about some of her research
on siblings of children with
autism and other topics.
From the MIND Institute Dr. Miller.
(audience clapping)
- Well thank you very much
for having me here today,
I'm going to be kind of doing.
I'm going to be shifting
gears a little bit I guess
from what you've been
talking about so far.
And spending some time
talking about autism
and also talking about very young kids
all the way up through
adolescents and adulthood.
I have nothing to disclose,
in terms of an overview
I'm going to tell you a
little bit actually not about
some of my research at the beginning.
I'm going to spend a little
time just to tell you
about some of the work that's
going on at the MIND Institute
that I'm not involved
in but I think you might
have interest in then I'll
talk about we've learned
about early detection
of autism by studying
younger siblings of children with autism.
Talk a little bit about
longer term outcomes of these
younger siblings of children
of autism in school age
which is some work that
I've been involved with
Sally Ozonoff at the MIND
Institute at also into
adulthood which is worked by some other
folks not at the MIND Institute.
And then I think after the Kagels talk
we'll have some time for questions.
So just to tell you a little
about the MIND Institute
if people aren't familiar it
was founded by six families
of children with autism and
the research and assessment
clinics opened in the late '90's.
So it's been around for about 20 years now
in name but the complex
the building itself
was built in 2003 and we
have a number of clinical
and research projects going
on at the MIND Institute
spanning a lot of
different areas including
research on using brain imaging.
So findings about boys
with autism who experience
regression having larger brain sizes.
Studies looking at risk
factors and protective factors
like the use of folic acid taken
preconception or prenatally
and that being related to
decreasing risk for autism.
There's studies of animal
models of neurodevelopmental
disorders and then I'll
talk a little bit about
studies focused on
early markers of autism.
There are other folks
at the MIND of course
that are studying early
interventions for autism as well.
And I'll talk about two
center grant projects
that have recently been
awarded to the MIND Institute
from the National Institutes health.
These are autism centers
of excellence or ACE awards
and the first one is
led by Dr. David Amaral
and it's focused on two subgroups
of children with autism.
So one is children with
autism who also experience
significant anxiety and
trying to understand better
how do identify that,
how do we diagnose it,
how do we treat it so
combine treatment study
of cognitive behavioral
therapy and medication.
They're also gonna looking
at brain imaging and whether
their brain changes in
response to treatment.
And then the other subgroup
their focused on is the group
of children with autism who
also have larger brains.
And this is really kind
of a basic science project
where they're gonna be trying
to determine which brain
systems are affected,
they're gonna use stem cells
to grow neurons, to identify
genetic changes that might
be related to enlarged brains.
So it's kind of a combination
of a clinical and a basic
science project and then the
other one that I'm gonna spend
a little more time to tell
you about mostly 'cause
I'm really excited about
it, I'm not involved in this
but it's led by Aubyn Stahmer.
And this is focused on kind
of the combined effort to
identify symptoms early but
also to intervene early.
And there's good evidence at
this point which I'll tell you
a bit more about later
that screening early
can detect autism earlier and the harm
from screening early
is likely to be small.
But there was this paper
that came out from the U.S.
preventive services task force suggesting
actually or concluding that
there is inadequate evidence
at this point that it has benefit.
That earlier intervention
necessarily has longer term
benefits or that early
detection has longer term
benefits when it comes
to early intervention.
There's a lack of research
studies that are focused
on treating cases of children
who have been identified
by early screening and so this
is a really big limitation
in trying to understand that
pipeline of early detection
to early intervention and
how that impacts outcomes.
So that's what this particular
ACE project is trying
to address this pipeline
of early screening
to early intervention and
then proving outcome overtime.
And this is a busy slide
but just to give you a sense
of what the study looks like,
they're actually intervening
firstly on providers, so
they're assigning providers
to either screen in a standardized
way, routine surveillance
or as usual how their
practice does autism screening
early in the first three years of life.
And then they're taking
the screen positive cases
and doing early intervention,
early start denver
model with these cases and
looking at various outcomes.
So the screening is
universal, they're screening
all children, the 18 month
checkup in the intervention
group meaning they're
intervening on the providers
and training them how to do this.
They're standardized so
they're screening the same way
using the Mchat and it's high fidelity.
So their goal is to avoid
all the common errors,
to encourage all screen
positive families to attend
a fuller evaluation and
potentially into their treatment.
So what they do after
there's a positive screen
or there's provider concerns,
they'll do an evaluation
if it's determined that
yes this child has autism.
They'll do a year of
intensive treatment and then
they'll document their
progress a year later
to see if this really
standardized high fidelity
way of doing early screening
has a higher probability
of getting kids into early intervention
and a higher probability
of improved outcomes.
We also have some clinics
at the MIND Institute
related to assessment
and diagnosis of various
neurodevelopmental disorders,
social skills programs.
So the big focus at the MIND
has been autism but we also
have research and clinical
services related to ADHD,
genetic syndrome and so
on and then we have also
have some educational
and outreach programs.
Centers for excellence in
developmental disabilities,
we have a post doctoral training program.
The autism research training
program and we're a LEND
site, Leadership Education in
Neurodevelopmental Disorders
as well and then also have a developmental
and behavioral pediatrics
fellowship program.
So now I'm gonna move into
talking a bit about early
detection of ASD and I've
sort of alluded to this
all ready but one of the
first questions is why.
Why do we care about early
detection and the idea
is we think that early
identification will result
in earlier treatment and
hopefully improved outcomes.
Now that ACE project led by
Dr. Stahmer will hopefully
prove that that's truly
correct and provide
us really solid evidence
of that but that's
a strongly held belief in
the field and probably true.
But more broadly it
could also have an impact
on decreasing service utilization cost
and economic broaden more broadly.
One of the big challenges
related to early detection
or one of the critique's
people might have is the risk
of false positives, so
identifying a child as having
autism, referring for treatment
but in fact we were wrong.
They didn't have autism and
they were just really young
but in general the interventions
that are commonly used
we tend to think that the benefits
likely outweigh that negative.
And really focusing on
infancy and early childhood
is a great time period
to try to understand how
these conditions develop
and to help with improving
accurate earlier detection,
identifying the time periods
that are most important for identification
and maybe early intervention
and what areas of functioning
are the most relevant in
this developmental period
that might help us
identify autism earlier.
So the next question is how do we do it.
And what I'm gonna tell
you about is one particular
study design that gets
used to try to identify
early signs of autism and
this is focused on siblings.
So it's called an infant
sibling study design
and what we do is we study families.
So we have the parents here
and then they have a child
with autism and then the family has a baby
and this baby is considered
to at elevated risk
for autism based on
family history genetics.
So we know the recurrent
rate of autism in younger
siblings of children with
autism is significantly higher
than the rate in the general population.
And then we have our
comparison group of babies
who have only typically
developing older siblings,
no family history of
autism spectrum disorder.
And then we have them come
into the lab for assessments
at regular intervals in the
first several years of life
so they would come in at
six, nine, 12, 15, 18,
24 and 36 months of life
and we'll do a whole
range of assessments with them.
Developmental assessments,
we'll do some eye tracking
assessments to see kind
of what they'll focus on
and are interested in, parents
will fill out a variety
of questionnaires,
starting at 18 months we'll
do an ADOS which is the Autism
Diagnostic Observation skill
and then when they turn three
we'll determine which babies
went on and developed autism by age three.
And which babies ended being
typically developing and then
we could go back and look at
all of the data and see where
the difference is between
those groups of children begin
to emerge and in what
areas of functioning.
So I'll just say that if a
child meets criteria before
age we will certainly make
the diagnosis and provide
referrals and recommendations
but kind of the final
determination for the
studies at age three.
Interesting I think excitingly
Sally Ozonoff has gotten
a follow up grant to study
cohorts of these babies
into school age period, so
now they're between seven
and fourteen and we're seeing them back
to see how they're functioning
later in development.
Whether they develop autism
or not so all of them.
So in terms of what we're
learning from siblings
in the infancy period,
we're learning about
the recurrence risk for autism,
we're learning about how
symptoms emerge on onset,
what are the early markers.
I'm not gonna talk
about biological markers
but some studies using
this study design do study,
they do brain scans or
EEG I'll talk a bit about
some of the behavioral markers.
And then we can learn more about target
for prevention and intervention programs.
So in terms of recurrence
risk, previously it was thought
that about three to 10% of
younger siblings of children
with autism would
develop autism themselves
which is significantly
higher than the population
prevalence but through these
infant sibling study design
there's a consortium
across the globe really
with multiple investigators
involved called the baby
siblings research consortium
and they've pooled their data.
They all sort of follow
this study design to answer
this question of what's
the updated recurrence rate
in these samples that we get
from these types of studies.
And it's much closer to
20% at least in these
infant sibling samples that we've studied
which is significantly
higher than we thought
and certainly significantly
higher than the general
population prevalence
of about one and a half
percent which was referenced earlier.
So that has some implications
I think about kind
of what families are thinking
about and I think it's helpful
to know just so you can monitor
and watch for early signs.
In terms of those early
signs and in terms of early
behavioral markers that
we might be looking for
especially thinking about
the symptoms of autism,
social communication
challenges and then also
thinking about infancy or early childhood.
We're really looking for
things like differences
in eye gaze, differences in
frequency of vocalization,
smiling or sharing their
affect with other people.
Responding to their names,
I'm gonna show you a little
bit of data about each of these
things that we've collected
through these studies and
this data was collected
through Sally Ozonoff
infant sibling studies.
And this was a paper she
published in 2010 where they
collected the data on these babies between
six and 36 months of age
and they video recorded
all of the assessments and
then they had people who
are trained up to really
high fidelity and reliability
to code very specific behaviors
that they saw in the videos.
Things like eye contact or
gazing into the face of the other
person in the video or
directing their smiles
to the other person or vocalizing.
And what you can see is this
group in red is the group
who went on to be diagnosed
with ASD by age three.
And you could see that in
these basic building block
social communication
behaviors, you see declining
trajectories or sort of
low flat trajectories
in the group who went
on to develop autism.
And the differences really
begin to emerge between
12 and 18 months of age or we
see these changes happening.
What I think is really
interesting and especially
for clinicians is that when
we ask clinicians to rate
very similar behaviors after
they have assessed the child
and these are blind examiners
they don't know anything
about the family history, they
don't know whether they're
at risk for autism or
not at risk for autism.
You see a really similar
pattern in these declining
trajectories of the examiner
or expert kind of clinician
ratings with the
differences really becoming
most different between 12 and 18 months.
So I think we can kind of get
at the same thing that this
pain staking really takes a
long time to do this coding
we can get at the same thing
from the clinician ratings.
In terms of another social
behavior that we've noticed
is different in infants who
are going on to develop autism
it's response to names, so
we know that infants use
their names as social cues
which helps them to orient
to salient aspects of
their environment including
social partners and what
has been shown in the past
is that there has been a
diminishment in the response
to name by about 12 months of age.
And this was found in
babies who developed autism
but this was found using retrospective
chart review or videos basically
or paper pencil measures
that parents fill out and
so we really wanted to look
at this from our
prospectively collected data.
And kind of overtime so the
developmental progression
of responding to name and what we found.
So we used a measure from
it's the AOSI, it's a task
that this is an item from
that task where examiner
calls the baby's name up to two times
and there are two trials like that.
So up to four total times at
different intervals during
the assessment and we
were pretty stringent
in our definition of a
failure so to fail we said
that they had to not respond
to any of the four trials.
And what we found was that the
group who went on to develop
autism was more likely to
fail by nine months of age
and persisting through 24 months of age.
So this appears to be
distinguishing that group
as early as nine months of age.
So ultimately I think this
work focused on infants
at risk for autism has
kind of resulted in a lot
important information
for clinical practice
and I think that it has made
its way into clinical practice.
Related to red flags and
early screenings for autism
in the first couple of years of life.
So I think families know
a lot more because they've
heard a lot more about these early signs,
they're watching for it, the
American Academy of Pediatrics
have implemented kind of
regular or universal screening
at specific intervals with recommended
measures early in life
so I think it has some
significant clinical impact thus far.
Now I mentioned earlier
that about just under 20%
of these infant siblings
go on to develop autism
by age three but so if you do your math
it means most of them don't, right.
So there's a question about
what about all of these
other children who were at
risk but did not develop autism
and so we've been interested
in this concept of the broader
autism phenotype so
sort of non diagnostic,
sub clinical, more like
traits or characteristics
that are kind of inline with
autism spectrum disorder.
So sub threshold social
communication challenges
for example but are not
at the clinical level.
And we see this sometimes in
family members of individuals
with autism and we were
interested in trying to understand
how early can we identify
those sub clinical differences.
So what we did was we
characterized our sample of these
babies when they were three,
whether they were typically
developing or non
typically developing based
on their MULLEN standardized
developing scores
and or ADOS scores being
within several points
of the autism cut off and
then looked backward to see
where did that group of
children start to differ
from the children who
were typically developing.
And the answer was around 12 months of age
that we say differences, so
again we can see differences
in these children who are
experiencing some threshold
challenges even earlier
than we kind of expected.
So now the question is
that's up to age three
and there's been a lot of
work across all of these
baby sibling consortium
sights to study these infant
siblings up to age three
but then it sort of stopped.
And of course we all know that
children continue to develop
and that's one of the reasons
that we've been interested
and Sally Ozonoff has been
interested in understanding
some of the longer term outcomes of these
siblings beyond the preschool period.
And again 80% of younger
siblings don't develop autism
but are there risks for
other things that come along
later in life, that's a
question that's worth answering
and the answer is generally yeah.
So about 35% we found of
children develop some other
non ASD concern by school age
that doesn't mean diagnosable
but some level of concern
across a variety of different
measures so I'll give you some examples.
This is sort of a pilot
project that was looking
at one cohort of these baby
siblings when they were
six to eight years of age,
so they had grown up into
that early school age period
and what we found here
is kind of when we looked
at it different ways we kind
of found the same thing
whether we were looking
at clinical concerns as
expressed by a clinician
who assessed the child or
scores above clinical cutoff
on measures of psycho pathology
symptoms like depression,
anxiety or autism related
symptoms or language scores
on standardized language testing.
We see a higher proportion
of the group who has a family
history of autism falling
into that impaired
or concerning range and
these are the children
who do not have autism themselves.
So I like I said anywhere
from 25 to 40% of these
siblings were falling into these sort
of elevated or clinical concern ranges.
Now one of the things that was
coming up in that age range
a lot for us was concerns
about ADHD and so we
did another sort of smaller
pilot where we looked
at eight to 11 years of age
and really tried to do a better
job of characterizing ADHD
and I think there is some
caveat I would mention
here, you could see a pretty
high rate of ADHD in our low risk group.
So it's certainly
possible that the families
that are most concerned
are the ones who came back
really easily but there
is a difference in terms
of the group that had a
family history of autism had
significantly higher rates of
ADHD than our low risk group.
So that kind of piqued our
interest and led to the current
follow up that we're
doing a little bit older,
12 to 15 years of age
for most of the children,
some of them may come in
a little earlier than that
maybe eight to 15 in the end
across three different cohorts
that had been recruited in
the last 15 years or so.
And we're doing more comprehensive
assessments of symptoms
of psychopathology like
ADHD, anxiety, mood concerns,
so we're doing a full diagnostic
workup on those things.
We're also assessing academic
skills, pragmatic language
abilities which we know are
challenging for children
with autism but also there's
suggestion that it may
be an area that's a little
bit challenging for siblings
who don't have autism, we're
kind of doing a deep dive
into their attention skill,
their activity level,
their ability to control
their inhibitions.
Or kind of inhibit the responses
and then lastly I think
really importantly their
peer relationships and social
functioning so we're having
teachers fill out ratings
about how well the child
is liked and how what their
social skills are like, how many friends
they have those kinds of things.
And one of the reasons we're
really interested in doing
this is because we really want
to understand how siblings
are functioning later in
development but we also see
these higher rates of other
kind of concerns outcomes
in this population and so
our thinking is that we might
be able by following them up
to use the data that we've
been collecting for the last
15 year for their whole lives
really to predict other
non autism outcomes.
Like what might be early
markers of ADHD, what might
be early markers of
anxiety in these siblings.
So I don't know if we'll
get to adulthood through
following these same
cohorts but there have been
certainly studies of
adult siblings of children
with autism, this is not work
that we've done ourselves.
But there was a study a
few years back by Holland
where they looked at 87
adult siblings of children
with autism, the average
age was just under 40.
And they had a group within
this group of siblings
a sub group that had previously
been evaluated at a prior
time point and identified
as either having that kind
of broader autism phenotype
traits and sub threshold
symptoms or traits
characteristics were unaffected
or typically developing and
when they followed them up
at this adult time point
what they found was that
the previously determined
or defined unaffected group
had average intellectual
functioning, basic academic skills.
They were functioning really well in jobs,
in their independence and
their social relationships,
so they were just functioning
average or above average.
The group that had been
previously identified as having
some of these sub threshold
characteristics had some
challenges with employment,
they had lower social
relationship levels and
they had elevated ASD traits
as would be expected as
well as elevated rates
of other mental health symptoms.
So this is I hope you can
see it relatively well,
but the group in pink is
that group that had the
sub threshold autism
traits in an earlier age
and what you can see here
is that they're elevated
across several different
aspects of functioning
so OCD symptoms, so
episodic depression symptoms
was the same but chronic
depression symptoms was different,
higher levels of anxiety and
higher rates of being above
a clinical threshold for
ADHD and these were symptoms
here that actually had
the required treatment.
So this was significantly
elevated symptoms,
so there do seem to be some
concerns that persist across
the lifespan for a subset
of siblings of children
with autism who don't
have autism themselves.
So just to summarize here
I would say that we've made
a lot of progress by studying
siblings in the early
detection of autism spectrum disorder.
That I do think have clear
implications for clinical
practice especially for
those of us who are working
in the early intervention,
early identification role.
The birth to three world
and I think as a result
of studying these baby
siblings we're realizing that
there's a really big
gap here that we really
don't know about longer term outcomes.
We've sort of just kind
of cut them off at three
and then moved on but we have
this opportunity to really
understand the full developmental
life course by continuing
to follow up these siblings
who have truly been enrolled
in these studies since the
beginning of their lives
which is pretty amazing, and
this could help us really
understand early predictors
of other outcomes
later in life like ADHD for example.
I think the other thing we
really need to do more of is try
to understand resilience
and protective factors
and I think these studies,
these samples really provide
an opportunity for that as well.
And so I think we'll
probably start to see more
of that over the next few years.
I just wanna put a plug out
because we're not too far
from the MIND Institute for
a study that I'm currently
doing and we have lots
of families who enroll
from the Bay Area but if you
have any clients or patients
or know any families
that might be interested
in this type of work where
we do kind of regular
close monitoring of
the babies development.
We're recruiting babies and
we're doing an infant sibling
study that's kind of combined
across autism risk and ADHD.
So we're also studying babies
at risk for ADHD to see
if we can apply the same
methods that have been so useful
in autism that have been
used to identify some early
markers of ADHD as well,
so there's information
there if you're interested,
so I'll just like to thank
the early risk study lab
which is my lab and the
infant sibling study which
is Sally Ozonoff's study.
A lot of the data that I
shared with you today is from
her research that I have
just been fortunate to be
a part of for the last several years.
As well as funding sources
and my contact information
is available here if you
have any follow up questions.
And I think there will
be a few minutes after
the Kagel's talk now, thank you very much.
(audience clapping)